Some kids are at a rest stop parking lot in the middle of August, waiting to get back in the car-- Logan, William, and Kieran. A reporter approaches them.
一些孩子八月中旬在高速休息站的停车场里等着回车上，他们是洛根、威廉和基兰。一位记者走了过来。
I couldn't help but notice that there's three of you guys. So the first question that pops into my head is, who's going to have to ride in the middle?
我不禁注意到你们有三个人。所以我脑海里蹦出的第一个问题是，谁得坐中间？
Unfortunately, me.
不幸的是，是我。
And how come you're the guy who has to ride in--
那为什么偏偏是你得坐——
Because those two, um, basically-- I don't know. They fight when they're in the middle. He doesn't even want to sit next to him. Ow. Stop that!
因为那两个，嗯，基本上——我不知道。他们坐中间的时候就会打架。他甚至不想坐在他旁边。噢。别那样！
He's pinching your cheek right now.
他现在正掐你的脸呢。
Pressure pointing, actually.
其实是在按压穴位。
So do you feel like this is going to be-- this is always going to be your job? As you guys get older, you're always going to be the brother sitting in the middle, brokering the peace?
那你觉得这会是——这会一直是你职责吗？随着你们长大，你是不是一直都要做那个坐在中间、负责调停的兄弟？
Yeah. And basically, I'm the mediator.
是的。基本上，我就是调解人。
How do you mean?
怎么说呢？
I'm not sure what you're talking about.
我不太确定你在说什么。
How do you mean you're the mediator?
你是说你作为调解人是什么意思？
I'm actually not sure what mediator means. I just felt like saying it. I think it means a guy who keeps peace. Like, keeping them from killing each other.
其实我不太确定调解人是什么意思。我只是随口一说。我想它的意思是负责维持和平的人。比如，不让他们互相伤害。
They can use a guy like you in the Middle East maybe.
也许中东地区能用到你这样的人。
One of the little brothers signals for the microphone.
其中一个弟弟示意要话筒。
Get it? Middle East. Because he's in the middle, and he's out east. Get it? Middle East.
听懂了吗？中东（Middle East）。因为他在中间（middle），而且他往东（east）边走。听懂了吗？中东。
There's nothing particularly notable about this rest stop. It's one of thousands all over the country, the kind of place we'd stop for 10 minutes on a holiday weekend, run inside, use the restroom, buy a burger or a coffee, head back out on the road.
这个休息站没什么特别的。它只是全国成千上万个休息站中的一个，那种我们在假期周末会停留10分钟的地方，跑进去用下洗手间，买个汉堡或咖啡，然后继续上路。
But if you stayed for more than 10 minutes, you might end up talking to one of these kids or to one of the couples who are dropping off children at college, like this reporter did.
但如果你停留超过10分钟，你可能会像这位记者一样，和这些孩子或者送孩子去上大学的夫妇聊上几句。
--the last kid off to school, so now we're the new empty nesters right now.
——最后一个孩子去上学了，所以我们现在成了新的空巢老人。
I know. How do you feel about that?
我知道。你对此感觉如何？
I'm cooking things that I've never tried.
我在做一些我从未尝试过的菜。
Yeah, and I'm eating things that I've never tried.
是的，我正在吃一些我从未吃过的东西。
There's some folks on the way back from a family reunion, might complain about the traffic.
有些人在从家庭聚会回来的路上，可能会抱怨交通。
And suddenly a clown truck filled with clowns cut us off.
突然一辆装满小丑的小丑卡车强行超车，把我们挤到了后面。
Or there's this guy, whose entertainment on his weekly four-hour drive isn't the radio or the CD player.
或者还有这个人，他每周四小时车程的消遣既不是收音机也不是CD播放器。
Well, truthfully, so none of the police folk out there are listening, I usually read the newspaper on the way up, or a book.
嗯，说实话，只要外面没有警察在听，我通常会在去程读报纸或读本书。
Are you kidding me?
你在开玩笑吧？
Here and there on the way up.
去程的路上偶尔读读。
And you've been doing it for six or seven years, and you've not had an accident?
你这样做了六七年，居然没出过事故？
No.
没有。
That seems to me to be pure luck.
在我看来这纯粹是运气。
There's a family driving six hours to visit their dad in prison; a young couple looking for a place to have their wedding; two brothers on the way to compete in the rodeo; a 16-year-old standing inside the rest stop nursing a tea, taking a break from her own family. She's on an eight-hour car trip with her dad, her grandma, her sister, and a couple of brothers. She explains to a reporter.
这里有一个开车六小时去看望入狱父亲的家庭；一对寻找举行婚礼场所的年轻情侣；两个正要去参加牛仔竞技比赛的兄弟；一个16岁的女孩站在休息站里喝着茶，从她自己的家庭中抽身休息一会儿。她正和她的爸爸、奶奶、姐姐以及几个弟弟进行八小时的公路旅行。她向记者解释道。
Well, it's very noisy, you could say that. Because everybody's arguing or talking about sports. We were just having an argument on who's better, Muhammad Ali or Mike Tyson? And Mike Tyson won. So my dad nearly stopped the car to argue and say, no, Mike Tyson is better. So it was just very hectic.
嗯，非常吵，可以这么说。因为每个人都在争论或讨论体育。我们刚才还在争论谁更厉害，穆罕默德·阿里还是迈克·泰森？结果迈克·泰森赢了。于是我爸爸差点停车争论说，不，迈克·泰森更厉害。所以当时真的非常混乱。
Coincidentally, a little later, Mike Tyson's name comes up again, in conversation with the prep cook named Ozzy, who works at the rest stop.
巧合的是，稍后迈克·泰森的名字再次出现在与休息站的厨师奥兹的谈话中。
Sometimes I see movie stars. I see Tyson in person.
有时我会见到电影明星。我亲眼见过泰森。
Mike Tyson.
迈克·泰森。
Mike Tyson was here. He has a tiny voice. How are you doing, man? Can I get ice cream? You know? So I see Mario Cuomo. I see this old lady who got a lot of plastic surgeries.
迈克·泰森来过这里。他的声音很细。你好吗，伙计？我可以买个冰淇淋吗？你知道吗？我还见过马里奥·科莫。见过那位做过很多整形手术的老太太。
Joan Rivers.
琼·里弗斯。
Yes, she was here, too.
是的，她也来过这里。
Poor Joan Rivers. The two strangers can get her name across simply by saying, "the old lady who got a lot of plastic surgery."
可怜的琼·里弗斯。这两个陌生人仅仅用“那个做了很多整形手术的老太太”就能传达出她的名字。
Nine of us came to this rest stop with tape recorders on a weekend in the middle of August, all the way back in 2009. Today's show is a rerun. It was two weeks before Labor Day, the time of year when over 10,000 people pass through this rest stop each day. We thought that, for once, we would not leave after just 10 minutes.
2009年8月中旬的一个周末，我们九个人带着录音机来到了这个休息站。今天的节目是重播。那是劳动节前两周，每年的那个时候每天有超过一万人经过这个休息站。我们想，为了改变一下，我们不再只停留10分钟就走。
Stick around and find out who all these people are, where they're going, what they're thinking about. We found love stories, and hardcore partiers, and inexplicably angry people, and all kinds of others. We bring you those stories in this special hour of our show for this holiday weekend when so many of us are on the road. WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
留下来，看看这些人都是谁，他们要去哪里，在想些什么。我们发现了爱情故事、狂热的派对爱好者、莫名其妙愤怒的人，还有各种各样的人。在这个假期周末，当许多人都在路上时，我们在这一个小时的节目中为您带来这些故事。这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，节目是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
The name of this particular rest stop is the Plattekill Travel Plaza. It's on the New York Thruway, I-87, about an hour and a half north of New York City on the northbound side of the highway. It's shiny and recently renovated with five restaurants in the food court-- Nathan's Hot Dog, Arthur Treacher's Fish and Chips, Roy Rogers, a Canadian sandwich shop called Brioche Duree, and a Starbucks-- plus a travel mart that sells sodas, and chips and gum, and stuff like that.
这个特定休息站的名字是普拉特基尔旅行广场。它位于纽约州高速公路I-87上，在纽约市以北约一个半小时车程的高速公路北行方向。它闪闪发光，刚装修不久，美食广场里有五家餐厅——内森热狗店、亚瑟·特里彻炸鱼薯条店、罗伊·罗杰斯快餐店、一家叫Brioche Duree的加拿大三明治店和星巴克——外加一家卖汽水、薯片、口香糖之类东西的旅行超市。
All these concessions and the cleaning crews and everything else are run by a company called HMS Host, which does this kind of thing in airports and travel plazas across the country. They have 120 employees here, and a half dozen managers, and a general manager.
所有这些特许经营店、清洁团队和所有其他一切都由一家名为HMS Host的公司运营，他们在全国各地的机场和旅行广场都做这种业务。他们在这里有120名员工，六位经理，还有一位总经理。
I think we have a very strong weekend as we get into the end of summer.
我想随着夏日临近尾声，我们会有一个非常强劲的周末。
This is the general manager, Robert Woodill, a friendly, upbeat guy who carries a folded piece of paper that he pulls out and unfolds and refers to constantly through the day, which has a list of sales figures for every half hour of the day.
这位是总经理罗伯特·伍迪尔，一个友好、乐观的家伙，他带着一张折叠纸，整天不断地掏出来展开查阅，上面列着每天每半小时的销售额数据。
All it simply is, is it's my half hour reports of last year on this day, so I can compare my sales the last year and see where we're at. And we do it usually at, like, 11 o'clock, and then every hour or so, we take a quick reading just to see where we're at.
这其实就是我去年的每日半小时报告，这样我就可以比较去年的销售额，看看我们现在的进度。我们通常在11点左右这样做，然后每隔一小时左右，我们快速查看一下，看看我们处在什么位置。
And explain when is the crazy time.
说说什么时候是疯狂的时候。
Today, it'll be probably from, like, 12 o'clock till 7 o'clock, very solid and steady. And then tomorrow morning, it'll pick up again. And I think as we're getting to the end of summer, there's a big race in Saratoga this week. People have booked their rooms for Lake George, and it's the end of summer. People want to go and go on vacation. So I think we're going to have a good weekend.
今天，可能会是从12点到7点，非常稳定且持续。明天早上，它会再次回升。我想随着夏天结束，本周在萨拉托加有一场大赛。人们预订了去乔治湖的房间，而且已经是夏天末尾了。人们想要去度假。所以我认为我们会有一个不错的周末。
We did our taping on Friday and Saturday, two weeks before Labor Day, because those are the biggest days and the biggest month here. In August, the rest stop makes a fourth of its money for the whole year. And it's crucial that Robert makes his goals this weekend because it's built into the rest stop business that there are a couple months every year when he just breaks even or loses money.
我们在劳动节前两周的周五和周六进行了录制，因为那是这里最忙碌的日子和月份。在八月，这个休息站赚取了它全年四分之一的收入。罗伯特必须在这个周末达到目标至关重要，因为休息站的经营模式决定了每年总有几个月他只能勉强保本或亏损。
Also, he wants to do better than his rival-- his rival, a rest stop in Maine, run by a guy named Andy Tucci.
此外，他想比他的竞争对手做得更好——他的竞争对手是位于缅因州的一个休息站，由一个叫安迪·图奇的人经营。
Kennebunk North, usually, and I are neck and neck. And we never place any wagers, but you know, they're Red Sox fans, we're Yankee fans. And we go back and forth on that, as well as discussing who's going to have the record sales for the day.
通常，我和肯纳邦克北站是不相上下的。我们从不打赌，但你知道，他们是红袜队球迷，我们是洋基队球迷。我们在这方面会有所交流，也会讨论谁当天的销售额最高。
Who won last weekend?
上周末谁赢了？
Andy. Andy beat me red like a lobster, if you want. That's what I told him. He beat me both days, but I think I'm going to get it back this weekend, so. I hope this week, the Yankees sweep the Red Sox, and then he'll be really quiet.
安迪。安迪把我赢惨了，如果要这么说的话。两天他都赢了我，但我认为这个周末我会赢回来。所以我希望这周洋基队横扫红袜队，那他就会安静下来了。
Robert was fully staffed for the rush. He had his best cashiers on. And now, he just needed the crowds, the big summer weekend crowds.
罗伯特为高峰期配备了充足的人手。他安排了他最好的收银员上岗。现在，他只需要人群，那个巨大的夏季周末人潮。
We chose this particular rest stop because, a couple years ago, I came here on the way to a wedding, and I noticed that a couple of the college students working at the Starbucks were speaking Polish. When I asked, they said, yeah, they were from Poland, here for the summer, on a special visa program called the J-1 program, where they live in the United States and work for three months at the rest stop and then get to travel for a month in America before flying home.
我们选择这个休息站是因为几年前，我在去参加婚礼的路上路过这里，我注意到在星巴克工作的几个大学生在说波兰语。当我问起时，他们说，是的，他们来自波兰，为了夏天来这里，通过一个叫J-1项目的特殊签证计划，在这个项目里他们住在美国，在休息站工作三个月，然后在飞回家之前可以在美国旅游一个月。
And it seemed like such a crazy thing to fly all the way to America and then be stuck behind a counter in the middle of nowhere for the summer. I wondered if they felt cheated. I wanted to come back and find out.
飞到遥远的美国，然后整个夏天被困在荒郊野外的一个柜台后面，这听起来真是太疯狂了。我想知道他们是否感到被骗了。我想回来一探究竟。
I'm Sandy, and I'm from Taiwan. And I work at Starbucks in Plattekill Travel Plaza.
我是桑迪，我来自台湾。我在普拉特基尔旅行广场的星巴克工作。
There are no Polish students this summer. It's mostly Taiwanese and Ukrainians working in Plattekill. Sandy's name back home is Moche Cho. She's a college junior and English major. This is her second year doing this summer work program. Last year, she was one of hundreds of foreign students who got jobs at Cedar Point Amusement Park in Sandusky, Ohio.
今年夏天没有波兰学生。在普拉特基尔工作的主要是台湾人和乌克兰人。桑迪在家里的名字叫莫彻·乔。她是大学三年级学生，主修英语。这是她参加这个暑期工作项目的第二年。去年，她是数千名在俄亥俄州桑达斯基的雪松点游乐园找到工作的外国学生之一。
But this year, she wanted to see a different part of the country and signed up for this location because of two magic words-- New York.
但今年，她想看看国家的不同部分，并因为两个魔术词报名了这个地点——纽约。
I love New York. Last year, I went to New York City just three days. So this time, I want to stay in New York City more.
我爱纽约。去年，我在纽约市只待了三天。所以这次，我想在纽约市多待一会儿。
And then when you got here, were you surprised how far it was from New York City?
当你到达这里时，你有没有惊讶于它距离纽约市有多远？
Yes, very surprised. Yeah. So actually, I'm a little regret about I choose this place, yeah.
是的，非常惊讶。是的。所以其实，我有点后悔选择了这个地方，是的。
She knew the rest stop wasn't in New York City. She just thought it would be a little closer and easier to get to. Without a car, everything's a hassle. So she hasn't seen New York at all this summer. The only place she's gone is some outlet stores. When she's not at work, she hangs around the apartment with five other students, all women who came over from Asia this summer to work at the rest stop.
她知道休息站不在纽约市。她只是以为它会近一点，更容易到达。没有车，一切都很麻烦。所以这个夏天她根本没去过纽约。她唯一去过的地方就是一些奥特莱斯商店。不工作的时候，她就和另外五名学生待在公寓里，她们都是今年夏天从亚洲过来在休息站工作的女性。
When we have day off, we will go to a supermarket to buy grocery. Yeah.
我们休息日的时候，会去超市买杂货。是的。
That's it?
就这些？
Maybe go to a restaurant to eat something.
可能会去餐馆吃点东西。
What's the best thing that's happened this summer on your trip?
你这次旅行中发生过的最好的事情是什么？
This summer? So far, I didn't make happiness in this trip. So far, no.
这个夏天？到目前为止，我在这趟旅行中没感受到快乐。到目前为止，没有。
Wait, you haven't had much that's been so good this trip?
等等，你这次旅行中没有什么太好的事吗？
No, so far.
没有，到目前为止。
So this seemed, frankly, a little sad. A bunch of students quietly tolerating their summers, counting the days until they could finally travel the country. Cooking food they don't eat, like hamburgers, and drinks they'd never heard of before arriving here, like frappucinos, all for people who have cars at a place that's all about cars on the side of the highway, but without cars of their own. I felt bad for them.
所以这看起来确实有点悲哀。一群学生静静地忍受着他们的暑假，数着日子直到他们终于可以去全国各地旅行。他们做着自己不吃的食物，比如汉堡，冲着他们来到这里之前从未听说过的饮料，比如星冰乐，这一切都是为了那些在高速公路旁这个一切以车为中心的地方拥有汽车的人们，而他们自己却没有车。我为他们感到难过。
And then I started talking to the Ukrainian students.
然后我开始和乌克兰学生交谈。
And how's it going?
现在进展如何？
Very good. I think that I really get a very big, huge experience here because I like this place, and I want to come back here. It's really true. I'm happy that I'm here.
非常好。我认为我在这里确实获得了非常巨大、丰富的经验，因为我喜欢这个地方，我想回到这里。这千真万确。我很高兴我在这里。
Evgenia Trekasa goes by the name Jane or Angelina here in the States. She's 18, entering her junior year of college. It's her first time away so long from her parents, and she misses them terribly, but it's also very exciting. She says that in the first week or two in Plattekill, she and the other Ukrainians felt stranded, same as the girls from Taiwan and Hong Kong felt.
叶夫根尼娅·特雷卡萨在美国叫简或安吉丽娜。她18岁，刚进入大学三年级。这是她第一次离开父母这么久，她非常想念他们，但这也非常令人兴奋。她说在普拉特基尔的头一两周，她和其他乌克兰人感到被困住了，就像来自台湾和香港的女孩们感觉一样。
Because that we don't have a car, we can't drive. We just can take a bus, so that's why. But then we find friends that, like, when we have a day off, they always can take us. Like, all the guys, it's OK. We will show you beautiful places. So when we have a day off, we always go to somewhere. We never stay at home.
因为我们没有车，我们不会开车。我们只能坐公交车，所以就是这样。但后来我们找到了朋友，比如当我们休息的时候，他们总是可以带我们。比如，所有的男生都说，没关系，我们会带你们去看美丽的地方。所以当我们休息的时候，我们总是去某个地方。我们从不待在家里。
What happened is that the Ukrainians befriended a couple of the American teenagers who work at the rest stop, and those teenagers introduced them to other young people. And before they knew it, they had rides to the mall, to Six Flags Amusement Park, to New York City.
发生的事情是，乌克兰人与在休息站工作的几个美国青少年交上了朋友，那些青少年把他们介绍给了其他年轻人。不知不觉中，他们就有了去商场、去六旗游乐园、去纽约市的车。
My name is Adelaide Giron. I'm 19. I work at Roy Rogers.
我叫阿德莱德·吉隆。我19岁。我在罗伊·罗杰斯工作。
Adelaide is a big, cheerful, fun-loving guy and probably the American who's gotten closest to the Ukrainians. In two years working at the Roy Rogers at the rest stop, he's seen lots of foreign students come through.
阿德莱德是一个高大、开朗、喜欢玩乐的家伙，可能是与乌克兰人走得最近的美国人。在休息站的罗伊·罗杰斯工作两年里，他见过许多外国学生经过这里。
I think this group has definitely, by far, been my favorite.
我想这一群人绝对是我目前为止最喜欢的一群。
Why?
为什么？
I felt like the other groups before, I've gotten attached to them. But this group, I think it's since I'm in college and they're in college. And we drink, and I drink, and they drink. And it's a fun experience.
我觉得以前的那些群体，我已经和他们产生过感情了。但这群人，我想是因为我在上大学，他们也在上大学。而且我们喝酒，我喝，他们也喝。这是一次有趣的经历。
I just recently got my license about two years ago-- actually, a year and a half ago. Before that, I was driving illegally, so I really couldn't drive all over the place. But now that I got my license, so, like, [BLEEP] I'm driving everywhere.
我最近才拿到驾照大约两年——其实是一年半前。在那之前，我是无证驾驶，所以我真的不能到处开车。但现在我拿到了驾照，所以，就像，去他妈的，我到处开车。
So I hang out with them. I take them shopping. At night, we go, like, swimming at this lake, trespassing. Who cares, though? Just having a good time. We're young. The cops showed up one time. We had alcohol on us. It was a pretty bad story.
所以我跟他们一起玩。我带他们去购物。晚上，我们去湖里游泳，那是擅自闯入。管他呢。只是玩得开心。我们还年轻。警察有一次出现了。我们身上带着酒。那是一个很糟糕的故事。
For a while, he says he was going over to their apartment three times a week-- Fridays, Saturdays, and Wednesdays for parties-- parties he taught them how to throw. Here's one of his students in this matter, Peter Molov, one of the Ukrainians.
有一段时间，他说他每周三次去他们的公寓——周五、周六和周三去参加派对——他教他们如何举办派对。这是他的一位学生，彼得·莫洛夫，乌克兰人之一。
What's your favorite thing that you've done so far since you've been here?
你到这里以来，做过的最喜欢的事情是什么？
Favorite thing? Probably the parties. Parties. They're a lot different than in our country. If we want to have parties, we just go to the club in our country, in Ukraine. Go to the club, loud music and stuff, you know.
最喜欢的事情？可能是派对。派对。它们和我们国家的很不一样。如果我们想开派对，我们就在我们国家，在乌克兰，去俱乐部。去俱乐部，大声的音乐之类的，你知道的。
But since we came here, we get to know other Americans, and they said, let's have a party. Well, OK, let's go to the club. Why to the club? Let's do it at home. OK. We go to home. They showed us games they play.
但自从我们来到这里，我们认识了其他美国人，他们说，咱们开个派对吧。嗯，好吧，去俱乐部吧。为什么要俱乐部？咱们在家开吧。好吧。我们回家。他们展示了他们玩的游戏。
Beer pong. Introduced them to my beer funnel-- they'd never seen that before. We showed them flip cup. We showed them how to play flip cup, and--
啤酒乒乓。把他们介绍给了我的啤酒漏斗——他们以前从没见过。我们展示了翻杯游戏。我们教他们怎么玩翻杯，而且——
I don't even know what that is.
我甚至不知道那是什么。
Really? It's a good buzz-getter.
真的吗？那是种很好的嗨翻方式。
It is fun. A lot of people play, so it's really fun.
真的很有趣。很多人一起玩，所以真的很有趣。
And you didn't have beer pong back in Ukraine?
你们在乌克兰没有啤酒乒乓吗？
No. I never knew.
没有。我从来不知道。
Will you be taking that back to show your friends back home?
你会带回这些去展示给家里的朋友们看吗？
Oh, yeah. We even want to buy a beer pong table, you know? Special for it.
哦，会的。我们甚至想买一张啤酒乒乓桌，你知道吗？专门用来玩这个。
I'm not sure they call it a beer pong table.
我不确定他们管那个叫啤酒乒乓桌。
They're pretty good for not knowing what beer pong is. Like, we just introduced them to beer pong two months ago, and yet, they're better than me. So yeah, we actually have, like, tournaments going on sometimes, and the Ukrainians end up on top most of the time. So yeah.
他们对于不知道什么是啤酒乒乓来说已经很厉害了。就像，我们两个月前才向他们介绍了啤酒乒乓，然而，他们比我还厉害。所以是的，我们有时确实会举行锦标赛，而乌克兰人大多数时候都是赢家。所以是的。
It's impossible to drink so much as Americans do. Americans really drink very much.
不可能像美国人喝那么多。美国人真的喝很多。
This is Dasha, another 19-year-old from Ukraine. She said most of the parties here in America in their apartment or out by the lake went until dawn.
这是达莎，另一位来自乌克兰的19岁女孩。她说美国大多数在他们的公寓里或湖边的派对都持续到黎明。
At 6:00 AM, 7:00 AM. And then the most fun is then when you work from 9:00 AM and you don't sleep at all. Like, one day, I just slept 30 minutes. I woke up and went to work.
早上6点，早上7点。然后最有趣的是你从早上9点开始工作，你根本没睡觉。就像，有一天，我只睡了30分钟。我醒来就去工作了。
That was the most fun?
那是最高兴的？
Yeah. As for me, I was dying at work.
是啊。对我来说，我在工作中简直要死了。
Fortunately, she works at a Starbucks. The Plattekill Rest Stop has employed foreign students for nearly a decade. They're hard workers and easier to schedule into shifts than American teenagers, who are always needing time off for family vacations, and sports practice, and other activities. There's a group in the summer and then smaller groups in the winter and spring.
幸运的是，她在星巴克工作。普拉特基尔休息站聘请外国学生已经有近十年了。他们工作努力，而且比那些总是需要请假参加家庭度假、体育训练和其他活动的美国青少年更容易安排班次。夏天有一群人，冬天和春天有较小的群体。
And the Plattekill Rest Stop is a close knit enough place that people cry when they leave. One of the managers told me how she still emails kids from Brazil and Peru who worked here years ago. At least one marriage has come out of this, between an American worker and a Bulgarian girl.
而且普拉特基尔休息站是一个关系足够紧密的地方，以至于人们离开时会哭。其中一位经理告诉我她仍然和几年前在这里工作的巴西和秘鲁的孩子们发邮件。这至少促成了一桩婚姻，是在一名美国员工和一名保加利亚女孩之间。
Though all the managers of the rest stop agreed that they like the Ukrainians, they're good kids, but the Ukrainians are the rowdiest group with the most issues they have ever had, hands down. Probably because the Ukrainians are the first group that were friends back in their home country. They came to Plattekill for a summer adventure.
虽然休息站的所有经理都同意他们喜欢乌克兰人，他们是好孩子，但毫无疑问，乌克兰人是他们有史以来最吵闹、问题最多的群体。大概是因为乌克兰人是第一批在他们的祖国就是朋友的群体。他们是为了夏日冒险来到普拉特基尔的。
They're having too much fun, one manager told me. Fireworks after 2:00 AM, complaints from neighbors. The police have come out a few times, because of the noise. Robert, the general manager, has no idea where he's going to find them housing if their landlord evicts them.
他们玩得太开心了，一位经理告诉我。凌晨2点后的烟花，来自邻居的投诉。因为噪音，警察来过几次。罗伯特，总经理，不知道如果房东把他们赶走，他该去哪里给他们找住处。
It's been a little bit of a rough summer with them. They're enjoying it. They're college kids. And I think the thing is they forget that they're not living in the dorms. They live in an apartment complex, where there's families, and kids, and little kids. So they just have to be more respectful at times.
和他们在一起的这个夏天有点艰难。他们很享受。他们是大学生。我想问题在于他们忘了他们不是住在宿舍里。他们住在公寓大楼里，那里有家庭、孩子和小孩。所以他们有时必须更尊重他人。
It's not like we don't want them have a good time. You got to make sure you draw the line someplace and say, OK, maybe 1 o'clock is late enough. Or the people are going to work because it's a Tuesday, and you just got to kind of be good neighbors.
并不是我们不想让他们玩得开心。你必须确保在某个地方划清界限，说，好吧，也许1点已经够晚了。或者人们要去上班，因为那是周二，你只是必须做一个好邻居。
As it turned out, everything came to a head the night before we arrived to record with an all-night party that Adelaide says was their craziest ever-- a party that was not thrown by the Ukrainians. It was the very first party thrown by the girls from Taiwan, total turnaround for them. Adelaide says before this, he and the Ukrainians had only invited them to one party.
事实证明，在我们到达记录的前一天晚上，因为一场阿德莱德说是有史以来最疯狂的通宵派对，一切达到了顶峰——那场派对不是乌克兰人举办的。那是台湾女孩们举办的第一场派对，对她们来说是个彻底的转变。阿德莱德说在此之前，他和乌克兰人只邀请过她们参加一次派对。
And they really don't drink, so they got drunk off a couple of beers. And we just-- they couldn't hang, so we just didn't invite them anymore.
而且她们真的不喝酒，所以她们喝了几瓶啤酒就醉了。然后我们就——她们玩不来，所以我们就没再邀请她们了。
But now they threw this party, a goodbye party for one of the girls who was leaving early, and they partied with the best of them, everybody dancing and making noise. After the second beer run, there was a late night beer fight with people pouring their drinks on each other. As usual, all this bothering the neighbors.
但现在她们举办了这场派对，为其中一个提前离开的女孩举办的告别派对，她们和最棒的人一起狂欢，每个人都在跳舞和制造噪音。在第二次买啤酒后，发生了深夜啤酒大战，人们互相往对方身上倒酒。像往常一样，这一切都打扰了邻居。
Then what was it, they complained to the landlord?
那是怎么回事，他们向房东抱怨了吗？
Yeah. The landlord doesn't like me or my other friends hanging around there. He actually refers to me as a big crazy Mexican that walks around, but. So I don't know. I don't think I'm a big crazy Mexican at all. I'm a gentle giant, really.
是的。房东不喜欢我和我的其他朋友在那里闲逛。他实际上称我为一个到处走的大疯墨西哥人，但是。所以我不知道。我不觉得我是一个大疯墨西哥人。我真的只是一个温柔的巨人。
And so then Robert had a talk with everybody?
然后罗伯特和大家谈了谈？
Yeah. He had a talk with everybody.
是的。他和每个人都谈了。
And it was kind of time to play the heavy-handed dad and just to make sure that they get the full message that this can't go on.
这有点像是要扮演严厉的父亲，确保他们充分理解这种事不能再继续了。
That we shouldn't have any more parties here. We should be quiet because if there will be one more party, they will send us home. They will, like, break our contract with Plaza, and then there will be no more students in Plaza the next year.
我们不应该再在这里举行派对了。我们应该安静点，因为如果再有一次派对，他们会把我们送回家。他们会，就像，撕毁我们和广场的合同，那么明年广场就不会再有学生了。
And what do you think of that?
你对此怎么看？
I don't know. Just, I don't really care they will have any other students next summer. Because I won't be there.
我不知道。我真的不在乎明年夏天是否会有其他学生。因为我不会在那里。
The American kids also got a warning from their boss. Again, here's Adelaide.
美国孩子们也从他们的老板那里得到了警告。再次是阿德莱德。
You know, just to stop going over there. The landlord doesn't want me on his property. He sees me or my car, it's getting towed at my expense. I'm going to get charged for trespassing.
你知道，就是停止去那里。房东不想让我出现在他的财产上。他看到我或我的车，我的车就会自费被拖走。我会因为擅自闯入被起诉。
And so what are you going to do?
那你打算怎么办？
Well, I'll probably still go over. [BLEEP] it. There's really nothing-- I mean, if they say anything, I'll just be like, oh, OK. It won't happen again, officer. And of course it'll happen again, but.
嗯，我可能还是会过去。去他妈的。真的没什么——我的意思是，如果他们说什么，我就说，噢，好的。这不会再发生了，警官。当然这还是会发生的，但是。
And do you worry that you could get the Ukrainians in trouble in a way that they'd get sent back early?
你担不担心你会惹上麻烦，让乌克兰人被提前遣送回去？
I hope not, but if they do, it's all a good time. And I told them if anything happens, I'm deeply sorry, but whatever happens happens. There's nothing we can do.
我希望不会，但如果发生了，至少大家都玩得很开心。我告诉过他们如果发生任何事，我深表歉意，但发生什么就发生什么吧。我们无能为力。
And that, everybody says, was the last big party of the year. But no matter. It was still a great summer. I asked Evgenia if she ever felt jealous of all the travelers she saw pass through the rest stop, people on the way to vacations while she was stuck working. And she said never. She'd come so far to get here.
每个人都说，那是今年最后一场大派对。但这无关紧要。那依然是一个很棒的夏天。我问叶夫根尼娅她是否曾嫉妒那些她在休息站看到的经过的旅行者，那些在她不得不工作时去度假的人。她说从来没有。她走得那么远才来到这里。
They should be jealous of me, because I'm here.
他们应该嫉妒我，因为我在这里。
Inside the rest stop, right when you enter the lobby, between the bathroom and the food court, is this room full of racks of brochures.
在休息站内部，当你进入大厅时，在卫生间和美食广场之间，有一个放满了宣传册架子的房间。
Lisa Pollak is one of the gang of nine reporters that we had at Plattekill.
丽莎·波拉克是我们普拉特基尔九人报道团队的一员。
You know those brochures you'll see in the lobby of a discount hotel, the ones advertising local attractions that inevitably, no matter where in the country you are, include a water park and an underground cavern tour? It's that, floor to ceiling.
你知道那些你在折扣酒店大厅看到的宣传册，那些广告宣传当地景点的，无论你在全国哪里，都不可避免地包括一个水上乐园和一个地下洞穴游览？就是那些，从地板到天花板都是。
This is the New York State Information Center. It confusingly is run not by New York State, but by a private company that charges businesses to display their pamphlets here. The manager of the center is a guy named Lenny Wheat. He also stands behind a counter offering travel advice to the lost.
这是纽约州信息中心。令人困惑的是，它不是由纽约州运营的，而是由一家私人公司运营的，该公司收取企业的费用在这里展示他们的小册子。该中心的经理是一个叫伦尼·惠特的人。他站在柜台后面，为迷路的人提供旅游建议。
When I talk to Lenny, he gets this look on his face, almost like he feels a little sorry for me. Because I think I'm in the middle of nowhere, and he thinks I have no idea what I'm missing.
当我与伦尼交谈时，他脸上露出一种表情，几乎像是他为我感到一点遗憾。因为我认为我身处荒郊野外，而他认为我根本不知道我错过了什么。
Right here, the next exit alone, you have best rock climbing in the country here.
就在这里，仅仅是下一个出口，你就有全国最好的攀岩胜地。
Oh, seriously?
噢，真的吗？
Yeah. It's the Napa Valley of the east around here. We have the oldest vineyards, the oldest winery, one of the best wineries. You have the best hotel resort spa in the United States in the area here, too.
是的。这里简直就是东部的纳帕谷。我们有最古老的葡萄园、最古老的酒庄、最好的酒庄之一。在这个地区，你还有美国最好的度假水疗酒店。
Wait, how do you know it's the best in the--
等等，你怎么知道它是最好的——
That's according to Mobil Travel Guide and Day Spa Magazine. I got one of the best dude ranches in the country up here by New Paltz, too.
那是根据《美孚旅行指南》和《日间水疗杂志》评选的。我在新帕尔茨附近也有全国最好的牧场度假村。
No, you don't.
不，你没有。
Yes, Rocking Horse Ranch Resort. Yeah, great place to take a family.
是的，摇马牧场度假村。是的，带家庭去的好地方。
By the time Lenny tells me about something called the Catamount Adventure Park-- largest adventure park in North America, according to the brochure--
当伦尼告诉我关于一个叫Catamount冒险公园的事情时——根据宣传册，它是北美最大的冒险公园——
There's 120 things to do there.
那里有120种活动。
--I am so overwhelmed by superlatives that I just take his word for it. Lenny knows this area. He's a local, lives eight minutes away. And he used to drive for a messenger service so he's an expert at getting directions. I found it especially impressive when he told travelers the exact number of miles between highway exits by memory.
——我被这些最高级的形容词淹没了，以至于我直接相信了他的话。伦尼很了解这个地区。他是当地人，住在八分钟路程外。他过去为快递服务开车，所以他是指路专家。当他凭记忆告诉旅客高速公路出口之间的确切英里数时，我觉得特别令人印象深刻。
But Lenny actually ended up in this job by accident. His neighbor used to work here, and Lenny would visit him from time to time to help out.
但伦尼其实是偶然得到这份工作的。他的邻居过去在这里工作，伦尼会时不时去拜访他帮帮忙。
And he was feeling ill one day, and I was like-- he says, you think you can stay here and do this? And I'm like, sure, why not? I mean, I know my way around. I know the roads, so. And he had some issues and stuff, diabetes and stuff, and wound up taking time out and stuff. He recently passed away and stuff.
有一天他感觉不舒服，我是说——他说，你觉得你能留在这里做这个吗？我说，当然，为什么不呢？我的意思是，我熟悉路。我认识路，所以。而且他有一些问题之类的，糖尿病之类的，最后不得不休假什么的。他最近去世了之类的。
I'm so sorry.
我很抱歉。
So but kind of like sometimes you feel like what you've done in your life is-- and it comes together, that it's like you were meant to do something, you know?
所以，但有时你会觉得你一生所做的事情是——它们结合在一起，就像你是注定要去做某件事的，你知道吗？
So you're saying it kind of seemed like it was meant to be?
所以你是说，这看起来像是命中注定的？
Sometimes it feels that way.
有时感觉就是那样。
I hung out with Lenny for a couple hours. I saw him cheerfully field dozens of information requests, everything from where to buy beer-- nowhere at the rest stop, but try New Paltz, there's a lot of college kids there-- to how to get to Maryland. A crucial first step-- turn around. Maryland is south of here. You are headed north.
我和伦尼待了几个小时。我看到他兴高采烈地处理了几十个信息请求，从哪里买啤酒——休息站没有，但可以试试新帕尔茨，那里有很多大学生——到怎么去马里兰。关键的第一步——调头。马里兰在南边。你正在往北走。
When anyone wanders in to browse, Lenny pounces.
当有人进来浏览时，伦尼就会扑上去。
What's your destination of today?
你今天要去哪里？
Lake George, the guy says.
乔治湖，那个人说。
OK. Can I get you anything for Lake George? We just got in the fall events guide, too.
好的。我可以为你去乔治湖提供什么吗？我们刚收到了秋季活动指南。
Sure, if you want to.
当然，如果你想的话。
Anything for Washington County on the other side of the lake? Anything on hiking?
在湖的另一边华盛顿县有什么？徒步旅行方面有什么吗？
No.
没有。
Waterways? Whitewater rafting?
水路？白水漂流？
Waterways.
水路。
Waterways, OK.
水路，好的。
Even though all these places are paying to advertise here, Lenny gets genuinely excited when he's pitching them. If he doesn't believe the Plattekill Rest Stop is the gateway to vacation gold, he sure fooled me.
即使所有这些地方都付钱在这里打广告，伦尼在推销它们时也表现得真心兴奋。如果他不相信普拉特基尔休息站是通往度假金矿的门户，那他肯定骗过我了。
And if he didn't know it, in Karo, there's bear statues all around the village, and there's a treasure hunt going on with that, OK?
而且如果他不知道的话，在卡罗，村庄周围到处都是熊的雕像，而且还有一个寻宝游戏，好吗？
Here's another one.
这还有一个。
And that is also the best concert facility in the world. Loggins and Messina's playing tonight.
那也是世界上最好的音乐会设施。洛金斯和梅西纳今晚有演出。
Who?
谁？
Loggins and Messina.
洛金斯和梅西纳。
Oh. Messina, the comedian?
噢。梅西纳，那个喜剧演员？
No. No.
不。不。
And one more.
还有一个。
And the world's largest kaleidoscope there, too.
那里还有世界上最大的万花筒。
Oh, beautiful.
噢，太美了。
Yes.
是的。
At a time when people plan their trips on computers and drive to them using GPS, it's a little surprising that a place like this even exists. I actually watched Lenny pull out a magnifying glass for a guy having trouble seeing a map. By the time I left, Lenny had me almost convinced that what he has to offer is better than the internet.
在人们用电脑规划行程并使用GPS驾驶的时代，像这样的地方还存在，这有点令人惊讶。我实际上看着伦尼为一个看地图有困难的人拿出了放大镜。当我离开时，伦尼几乎让我相信他所提供的比互联网更好。
You can sit here in 10, 15 minutes, flip through the pages, and seen most everything every county might have to offer you. You know how long it would take you to find all that on the internet? You turn the page, you got shopping. You turn the page, you got your fishing, your antiquing.
你可以坐在这里10、15分钟，翻翻页面，看到每个县可能为你提供的大部分东西。你知道在互联网上找到所有这些需要多长时间吗？你翻开页面，你有购物。你翻开页面，你有钓鱼、古董店。
How're you doing, guys? Where are you going to?
你们好吗，伙计们？你们要去哪里？
You know, you don't really go on a long car trip with strangers. Usually you're with people who you know really, really well. And being confined in the car together in a tiny space, staring ahead at the road, that's one of the nicest places to talk, have a long, long talk.
你知道，你其实不会和陌生人进行长途公路旅行。通常你和那些你非常、非常熟悉的人在一起。被困在狭小的车厢空间里，一起盯着前方的道路，那是最好的谈话、进行长久、长久交谈的地方之一。
One woman told us that she actually plans things to discuss with her husband and her kids when she knows that they're going to be in the car for hours. Another woman, this mom named Elizabeth McMann, was driving from DC to Albany with her 9-year-old. It's a long drive. And the son decided that he was going to use the time to get to the bottom of some things.
一位女士告诉我们，她实际上会规划好要和丈夫及孩子讨论的事情，当她知道他们要在车里坐上几小时的时候。另一位女士，这位叫伊丽莎白·麦克曼的妈妈，正带着她9岁的儿子从DC开车去奥尔巴尼。这是一段漫长的旅程。儿子决定利用这段时间把一些事情问个水落石出。
He's been on this whole Q&A thing, where, Mom, who do you like better, your sister or your brother? Uncle Jenny or Uncle Chad? Or how long would you cry if I died? Or would you rather be married to your old boyfriend or to Daddy, who's-- we're divorced. He's been kind of weird. So that stimulates some conversation. He just asked, for example, Mom, are you really Santa Claus?
他一直在进行某种问答游戏，妈，你更喜欢谁，你姐姐还是你哥哥？詹妮阿姨还是查德叔叔？或者如果我死了你会哭多久？或者你更愿意嫁给你的前男友还是爸爸，谁是——我们离婚了。他一直有点怪。所以那刺激了一些对话。他刚刚问，例如，妈，你真的是圣诞老人吗？
The reporter who talked to that woman was Jonathan Goldstein. He mostly stationed himself outside the rest stop in the parking lot by the picnic benches. Somehow, everybody Jonathan talked to seemed to be enjoying their time on the road to the max.
和那位女士交谈的记者是乔纳森·戈尔茨坦。他主要驻扎在休息站外的停车场野餐长凳旁。不知何故，乔纳森交谈的每个人似乎都在享受着他们在路上的时光。
Stan is sitting on the bench in front of the parking lot. Unlike everyone else you see-- people looking to eat, looking to get to a washroom-- Stan looks perfectly at home, smoking a cigar like he's got the world on a string. Like hanging out at a rest stop is the best part of any vacation. He's waiting for his girlfriend, who he likes to call--
斯坦坐在停车场前的长凳上。不像你看到的其他人——那些想要吃东西、想要找洗手间的人——斯坦看起来非常自在，抽着雪茄，好像他把世界玩弄于股掌之间。好像在休息站闲逛是任何假期最好的部分。他正在等他的女朋友，他喜欢叫她——
The War Department.
战争部。
And by which you mean?
你的意思是指？
It's my girlfriend. The War Department, or the wife, is the War Department. Get with it, baby. Let's go, baby. It's always sort of the sky is very clear and blue today. That's not blue. That's not blue. That's not clear.
是我女朋友。战争部，也就是老婆，就是战争部。跟上节奏，宝贝。走吧，宝贝。今天的天空总是显得格外晴朗蔚蓝。那不是蓝色。那不是蓝色。那并不晴朗。
Have you guys been arguing a lot in the car?
战争部。
No, we never argue. She told me to say that. This is me. See this, under the thumb? Yes, dear. Yes, dear. That's me, right there. Yes, dear.
你的意思是指？
And yet, in spite of Stan's take on couplehood-- one perhaps modeled on Warner Brothers cartoons of the '50s-- it looks like there's still a never ending line of people all too eager to sign up. Case in point-- a group of four women come striding across the parking lot in the midst of a bachelorette party.
那是我女朋友。战争部，或者妻子，就是战争部。跟上节奏，宝贝。走吧，宝贝。总是有点像是今天天空非常清澈和蔚蓝。那不是蓝色的。那不是蓝色的。那不清楚。
Oh.
你们在车里吵了很多架吗？
It's a surprise because it's a bachelorette party. We're taking her away somewhere she's never been before.
不，我们从不吵架。她叫我这么说的。这是我。看到这个了吗，在她的掌控之下？是的，亲爱的。是的，亲爱的。那就是我，就在那儿。是的，亲爱的。
And how do you feel about that?
然而，尽管斯坦对夫妻关系的看法——也许是模仿了50年代华纳兄弟的动画片——看起来仍然有一长串迫不及待想要报名的人。例子——四个女人正大步穿过停车场，处于单身派对之中。
I feel like I need to know where I'm going pretty soon.
噢。
Do you even know in what direction you're heading?
这很惊喜，因为这是一个单身派对。我们带她去一个她从未去过的地方。
North.
你对此感觉如何？
And that's it? That's all you know?
我觉得我很快就需要知道我要去哪里。
Well, the only thing I know is that I need flip-flops, a whistle, and something else. Yeah, flip-flops and a whistle.
你甚至知道你在往哪个方向走吗？
Now does that really come into play, or are you just messing with her mind at this point?
北。
It's very important. It's very important to the whole evening.
就这样？这就是你知道的全部吗？
Flip-flops and a whistle, I'm thinking some--
嗯，我唯一知道的是我需要人字拖、口哨和别的东西。是的，人字拖和口哨。
And comfortable clothes.
现在那真的派上用场吗，还是你只是在戏弄她？
All right, now I'm going to ask you guys-- I'll ask you to step over there. I'm going to ask these guys what they've got planned. And I won't tell anything, and by the time this airs, it won't make a difference. So you're just going to go stand over there, I'm sorry. Because now I'm going to get this scoop. All right, just crowd in here.
这非常重要。这对整个夜晚非常重要。
All right, so flip-flops and a whistle, what's that all about?
人字拖和口哨，我在想——
It's all crap. It's complete crap. We're making the whole thing up.
还有舒适的衣服。
My name's Jack, man.
好了，现在我要问你们——我要请你们站到那边去。我要问问这些人他们计划了什么。我不会说出任何事，等这播出的时候，也没什么区别了。所以你们只是去那边站着，抱歉。因为现在我要拿到独家新闻。好了，挤到这里来。
And where are you coming from?
好了，人字拖和口哨，那到底是什么意思？
I'm coming from mother [BLEEP] Boston, heading to West Virginia.
那全是废话。完全是废话。我们编造了整件事。
What's your last name?
我叫杰克，伙计。
I ain't getting into that right now. No last names on this. I've been drinking.
你从哪里来？
As it turns out, Jack is not the one driving. He's traveling with a couple friends back from mother [BLEEP] Boston, where he's dropped off his four-year-old, who he spent the summer with in West Virginia. Jack has four kids in three different states. Each of their names are tattooed across his upper torso. Jack is on his way home.
我从他妈的波士顿来，要去西弗吉尼亚。
Got lost a couple times, so it took us, like, 12 hours.
你姓什么？
So how long was he with you?
我现在不想说这个。这上面没有姓。我喝醉了。
Probably, like, three, four months.
事实证明，杰克并不是开车的人。他和几个朋友从他妈的波士顿回来，他在那里送走了他四岁的孩子，他曾和孩子在西弗吉尼亚度过了一个夏天。杰克在三个不同的州有四个孩子。每个孩子的名字都纹在他的上躯干。杰克正在回家的路上。
And you only get to see him during the summer?
走错了好几次，所以我们花了大概12个小时。
Nah, I get him for Christmas. You know how the women are. They don't want to pay for all the Christmas presents and stuff. You know what I mean? They all make sure the kids are with me for Christmas.
那他和你在一起待了多久？
And you saw his mom, too, when you pick him up and drop him off?
大概，三、四个月。
Oh, yeah. I still got the big red marks on my back where she tried to beat me up.
你只有夏天才能见到他吗？
Are you kidding?
不，我圣诞节会接他。你知道女人们是什么样的。她们不想支付所有的圣诞礼物之类的。你知道我的意思吗？她们都确保孩子们在圣诞节和我在一起。
Nah, man. I'm for real. Hey, don't bring your new girlfriend to your ex-wife's house. That's all I got to say. That baby's mama drama stuff, you know. Seeing how she's on crutches, and she broke her leg a few weeks ago, she tried to beat me up with her crutches.
你接送他的时候也会见到他的妈妈吗？
Your new girlfriend's in the car with you now?
哦，会的。我背上还有很大的红色印记，那是她试图打我时留下的。
Yeah, man, yes. That's the pretty blonde over there in that black car. You walk over there, you'd be surprised, though. Her and my buddy driving, we call him Hot Wheels. He's a handicapped kid in a wheelchair, so you know what I mean? We nicknamed his ass Hot Wheels.
你在开玩笑吧？
I walk across the parking lot to a big black rusty car.
没有，伙计。我是认真的。嘿，别带你的新女朋友去你前妻家。这就是我要说的全部。那些孩子妈妈的戏码，你知道的。看她拄着拐杖，几周前骨折了，她试图用她的拐杖打我。
Jack told me they call you Hot Wheels.
你的新女朋友现在在车里和你一起吗？
Yeah, 'cause I'm always in a wheelchair. Tore my foot off.
是的，伙计。那是那辆黑色轿车里的漂亮金发女郎。你走过去，你会感到惊讶的。她和我开车的哥们儿，我们叫他“风火轮”。他是个坐轮椅的残疾孩子，所以你知道我的意思吗？我们给他的屁股起了个绰号叫“风火轮”。
How did that happen?
我走过停车场来到一辆又大又黑生锈的汽车旁。
A car crash back in 2006. Hit a wall at about 100. What do you expect? You don't expect to walk away from something like that.
杰克告诉我他们叫你“风火轮”。
And you are-- you're in the back seat here.
是的，因为我总是坐轮椅。把脚撞烂了。
Krissy.
那是怎么发生的？
You're also from West Virginia?
2006年的一场车祸。以大约100英里的速度撞墙。你期待什么？你不会指望从那样的事故中走出来。
Yes.
而你——你坐在后座。
And how old are you guys?
克里西。
I'm 21.
你也是西弗吉尼亚人吗？
And Krissy?
是的。
24.
你们多大了？
Do you do much traveling?
我21岁。
No, not at all. I'm a stay-at-home mom, so.
克里西呢？
How old are your kids?
24。
I have one. He's nine.
你们经常旅游吗？
So you don't get a chance to travel very much.
不，一点也不。我是全职妈妈，所以。
Right. It's been a long trip.
你的孩子多大了？
Is this the furthest you've been?
我有一个。他九岁。
Yes. I went to New Jersey once before, but other than that, this is definitely the farthest and longest.
所以你没有机会经常去旅行。
And have you been in a lot of, like, parking lots like this, a lot of rest stops?
是的。这是一段漫长的旅程。
Actually, no. I think this is probably the first, like, rest stop I've ever come to.
这是你去过最远的地方吗？
Not in your life?
是的。我以前去过一次新泽西，但除此之外，这绝对是最远和最长的一次。
Yes.
你们去过很多像这样的停车场，很多休息站吗？
Really?
其实没有。我想这可能是我去过的第一个休息站。
Yes. I don't just live in West Virginia. I live in West Virginia, and I don't ever go anywhere.
你一辈子都没去过？
Coming up, love in the middle of the night, and much more. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
是的。我不仅仅是住在西弗吉尼亚。我住在西弗吉尼亚，我哪儿也不去。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Rest Stop. Nine of us stayed for two days in the middle of August at the Plattekill Travel Plaza on the northbound side of I-87 in New York State. This was back in 2009 that we did this. Today's show is a rerun. We were talking with the people passing through, most of them on vacation, and of course, with the people who stay at the rest stop, working.
接下来，深夜里的爱情，还有更多。从芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目将在稍后继续。
I'm still waiting for Andy's report back. Let me see if he sent anything back.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，带给你围绕该主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目是：休息站。我们九个人在8月中旬在纽约州I-87北行方向的普拉特基尔旅行广场停留了两天。那是2009年我们所做的。今天的节目是重播。我们和经过这里的人交谈，他们大多数都在度假，当然，还有那些留在休息站工作的人。
3 o'clock, Friday. Robert, the general manager at the rest stop, checks his BlackBerry for an email from his rival in Maine, Andy Tucci. Noon to 3:00 was supposed to be some of the busiest hours of the year for Robert, but he does not look happy. He's not hitting the half hourly goals on that piece of paper that he carries around with him.
我还在等安迪的回复。让我看看他有没有发什么过来。
I am down a bunch from last year, about $3,300 behind last year and $600 behind last week, which is not a normal thing. And so it's a little cause for concern right now. So right now, we're not sure why. There doesn't seem to be a lot of traffic problems. We can make it up. In an hour and a half, we can make it all back and be right where we're supposed to be, so.
周五3点。休息站的总经理罗伯特查看他的黑莓手机，看有没有来自他在缅因州的竞争对手安迪·图奇的邮件。中午到3点本应是罗伯特一年中最繁忙的时间段，但他看起来并不高兴。他没能达到他随身携带的那张纸上的每半小时目标。
Every couple hours when I check with Robert, this is what he says. We can still make it up. The rush still can come. Robert is optimistic, mostly.
我比去年少了好多，比去年落后了约3,300美元，比上周落后了600美元，这不是常态。所以现在有点令人担忧。所以现在，我们不确定为什么。似乎没有很多交通问题。我们可以弥补回来。在一个半小时内，我们可以把一切都赚回来，回到我们应该在的位置，所以。
I wonder how it's going in Maine.
每隔几个小时当我向罗伯特查看时，他都是这么说的。我们仍然可以弥补。高峰期仍然可能到来。罗伯特是乐观的，大部分时候。
I haven't emailed Andy yet, but I'm afraid to email Andy right now. I'm sure it's going very well. But maybe that's a good thing I haven't heard back from Andy.
我不知道缅因州的情况如何。
Now it's starting to get a little overcast outside.
我还没给安迪发邮件，但我现在怕给安迪发邮件。我相信情况非常顺利。但也许我还没收到安迪的回信是一件好事。
So what, are you wishing for rain here?
现在外面开始有点阴天了。
Actually, he tells me, rain isn't always bad.
所以呢，你是在这儿祈求下雨吗？
If it rains at the right time, people get backed up in traffic, then they gotta stop. 'Cause now they've been in traffic a little longer, so perfect timed rainstorms will be nice, and maybe not too hard. I think that'll be good because people will get out of their car and walk in a light rain, but they don't want to walk in a downpour. If it's a downpour, they don't come out of the car. We'll keep our fingers crossed. Still got a lot of night to go, so.
其实，他告诉我，下雨并不总是坏事。
Fingers crossed.
如果雨在正确的时间下，人们就会被堵在车流里，然后他们就得停下来。因为现在他们已经在车流里待得更久了，所以定时完美的雨暴会很不错，而且也许不要太大。我想那会很好，因为人们会在小雨中走下车，但他们不想在倾盆大雨中走动。如果是倾盆大雨，他们就不会下车。我们会祈祷好运。夜晚还很长，所以。
You're killing me, man.
祈祷好运。
Within 25 minutes, the skies literally blacken.
你真是要了我的命了，伙计。
[THUNDER]
在25分钟内，天空完全变黑了。
And it is the wrong kind of rain, the kind that includes tornado warnings one county over, the kind where you do not run from your car across the parking lot to buy a nice sandwich or a hot coffee from Robert. The kind that I figured would just please one person on this earth, and that person was in Maine.
（雷声）
I would say probably by his last email, we're probably right in the same boat, right in the same area.
这是一种错误的雨，那种包括邻县龙卷风警报的雨，那种你不会从车里跑出来穿过停车场去买一个美味的三明治或从罗伯特那里买杯热咖啡的雨。那种我觉得只会让地球上一个人高兴的雨，而那个人就在缅因州。
Ladies and gentlemen, Andy Tucci, Roberts' rival, general manager of the Kennebunkport Travel Plazas. And his day actually wasn't going great either yet.
我会说大概根据他最后的一封邮件，我们大概处在同一条船上，处于同一个区域。
Yeah, I just shot him an email, letting him know that we'd be busy later on after the Red Sox game.
女士们先生们，安迪·图奇，罗伯特的竞争对手，肯纳邦克波特旅行广场的总经理。他的一天其实也没好到哪里去。
Oh, I see. Oh, you think you can make it up later.
是的，我刚发了一封邮件给他，让他知道我们红袜队比赛后会很忙。
I think so. There'll be a lot of people on the road later on celebrating. Well, these Boston fans will be.
噢，我明白了。噢，你认为你稍后可以弥补回来。
Celebrating, huh?
我想是的。稍后路上会有很多人在庆祝。嗯，这些波士顿球迷会的。
Celebrating, absolutely.
庆祝，哈？
Now later on, does he have anything going on?
庆祝，绝对是的。
I don't really believe he has a whole lot going on down here tonight, you know, the Yankees being on the road.
那稍后，他有什么活动吗？
So it's looking pretty bad for him.
我不认为他今晚在这里有什么太大的活动，你知道的，洋基队在客场比赛。
I would say so.
所以对他来说情况看起来很糟。
At one point, finally, one of the concession stands, Nathan's Hot Dog, does get a real rush with a line that extends to the middle of the food court. This is where speed becomes crucial. Robert says that if people walk into the rest stop and see a line, if the line doesn't seem like it's moving, they'll walk out without buying. So his staff has to pour it on during the rush if they're going to make their goals and, of course, beat Maine. Sean Cole went behind the Nathan's counter to watch the action.
我会这么说。
Every now and then during the rush, Nathan's runs out of food.
终于有一次，其中一个特许摊位，内森热狗店，确实迎来了一次真正的高峰，排队排到了美食广场的中间。这就是速度变得至关重要的地方。罗伯特说如果人们走进休息站看到排队，如果队伍看起来没在动，他们就会不买就离开。所以他的员工如果想达到他们的目标，当然，还要打败缅因州，就必须在高峰期全力以赴。肖恩·科尔走到内森柜台后面观看行动。
Wow, there's only one corn dog.
高峰期间，内森偶尔会食物耗尽。
Heather Rafertee's working one of three cash registers. One corn dog is a problem since a customer has been waiting a long time for two. They prepare as well as they can here, but there's only so much food you can cook in advance. Heather has to grab parts of other people's orders just to keep the flow going.
哇，只剩一个玉米热狗了。
I'm taking one of your large fries. You're waiting on nuggets anyway.
希瑟·拉弗蒂负责三台收银机中的一台。一个玉米热狗是个问题，因为有个顾客已经等了很久要两个。他们在这里尽可能做好了准备，但你预先能煮的食物毕竟有限。希瑟必须抢夺其他人的订单部分来保持流量。
It's like putting together a puzzle where a lot of the pieces are exactly the same shape. And it'd be easy if it wasn't so hard. People are fanatical about Nathan's, and workers joke about it. They feel like saying, you know, Roy Rogers has food, too. Luckily, Heather's break is imminent.
我要拿走你的大份薯条。反正你还在等鸡块。
I've got four minutes. Four long minutes.
这就像在拼一个很多碎片形状完全一样的拼图。如果没这么难的话，会很容易。人们对内森是狂热的，员工们对此开玩笑。他们感觉想说，你知道，罗伊·罗杰斯也有食物。幸运的是，希瑟的休息时间即将来临。
Four long minutes later, she clocks out and sneaks through the maze-y hallway in the back. On her way out the back door for a smoke, she walks up to another worker--
我有四分钟。漫长的四分钟。
Alex.
四分钟漫长的四分钟后，她打卡下班，穿过后面的迷宫般走廊。在从后门出去抽烟的路上，她走向另一个员工——
--and gives him a quick passing smooch, which made me feel like I was really behind the scenes. Alex is Heather's boyfriend. About four months ago, they had a kid, a little boy. I ask what it's like to live and work together, but Heather says they don't. She lives with her parents right now and the baby.
亚历克斯。
And Alex lives with his family. We're still together, definitely, but we plan on moving in together at some point. It's just that right now, money's tight, and this was kind of-- as much as I love my son, he was kind of like a surprise, so. Yeah, so. But eventually down the road, me and Alex will move in with each other.
——给了他一个快速的擦身之吻，这让我感觉我真的在幕后。亚历克斯是希瑟的男朋友。大约四个月前，他们有了一个孩子，一个男婴。我问住在一起和一起工作是什么感觉，但希瑟说他们没有。她现在和父母以及孩子住在一起。
And you're thinking of getting married and--
亚历克斯和他的家人住在一起。我们仍然在一起，绝对是的，但我们计划在某个时候搬到一起住。只是现在，钱紧，而且这有点——尽管我爱我的儿子，但他有点像是一个惊喜，所以。是的，所以。但最终，我和亚历克斯会搬到一起住。
I'm hoping so. We've been together for two years now, so I'm definitely considering it. But he's 20 years old. He just turned 20 in June, so he's kind of still young, so.
你在考虑结婚和——
And how old are you?
我希望如此。我们在一起两年了，所以我绝对在考虑这件事。但他才20岁。他六月份刚满20岁，所以他还是有点年轻，所以。
I'm 21.
你多大了？
Heather and Alex are a mixed couple. She works at Nathan's, he works at Brioche Duree, the pastry and sandwich shop at the rest stop. This has led to a little inter-restaurant tension in the relationship.
我21岁。
He's like, well, I worked this shift. I'm like, well, I worked this shift, and it was busy like this. And he's like, well, it was like this. And you know, we get into debates.
希瑟和亚历克斯是一对混合情侣。她在内森工作，他在休息站的糕点和三明治店Brioche Duree工作。这导致了关系中一点点餐馆间的紧张。
Over who is more busy.
他说，嗯，我上了这个班。我说，嗯，我上了这个班，而且像这样很忙。他说，嗯，是这样的。你知道，我们陷入了争论。
Yeah. And which one's more crazier and which one's more harder, so.
关于谁更忙。
I've not been privy to these debates, and I don't work at the rest stop, but no one's fanatical about Brioche Duree. Nathan's is way harder.
是的。还有哪一个更疯狂，哪一个更辛苦，所以。
Across the lobby, all the way across on the other side from Nathan's, over in the travel mart, another one of our reporting team, Gregory Warner, was there when cashier Clara Dragon started her shift.
我没有参与这些争论，我也不在休息站工作，但没有人对Brioche Duree狂热。内森要辛苦得多。
First thing Clara does on her shift, before she rings up a sale or even opens her register, she picks up a three-foot cardboard display of Purell hand sanitizer and sets it down on one side of the cashier's counter. It's a simple maneuver that blocks and redirects the flow of customers. Without it, she'd get bombarded from both sides.
穿过大厅，在离内森最远的另一侧，在旅行超市里，我们的另一位报道团队成员，格雷戈里·华纳，在收银员克拉拉·德拉贡开始上班时就在那里。
Because they'll come over here ahead of the other people, and it causes an argument. So I barricade it so that they know they gotta go over there.
克拉拉上班的第一件事，在她成交或打开收银机之前，她拿起一个三英尺高的Purell洗手液纸板展示架，放在收银台的一侧。这是一个简单的动作，阻挡并重定向了顾客流。没有它，她会从两边受到轰炸。
This stack of two-ounce Purell--
因为他们会跑到这里跑到别人前面，这会导致争吵。所以我设置路障，让他们知道他们必须去那边。
Keeps them from standing here and cutting the people off. Everyone says I'm crazy, but I do it immediately when I come in. Plus, it saves arguments. You don't want to rile them up more than they already are.
这一堆两盎司的Purell——
Clara grew up in a rough part of Astoria, Queens and spent her youth staying out of the way of trouble. At Plattekill, she's worked nine years as waitress and then cashier.
让他们不再站在那儿插队。每个人都说我疯了，但我一进来就立刻这样做。另外，这节省了争论。你不想让他们比现在更愤怒。
I was a waitress in Bob's Big Boy. And when they shut that down, they opened this, and I jumped in here.
克拉拉在阿斯托利亚、皇后区的一个粗糙地区长大，度过了她远离麻烦的青春期。在普拉特基尔，她做了九年服务员，然后是收银员。
So, um--
我在鲍勃大男孩当过服务员。当他们关闭那个时，他们开了这个，我就跳进来了。
Ask her if she voted for Barack Obama and if she thinks he's a good president or is he a [BLEEP]?
所以，呃——
A tall guy with a sunburn and a pink polo shirt wags a Butterfinger bar.
问问她是否投票给了巴拉克·奥巴马，是否认为他是一位好总统，还是他是个混蛋？
Ask her. She'll tell you. Do you think Obama's going to give you free health care, and do you think you deserve it?
一个晒伤严重、穿着粉色Polo衫的高个子挥舞着Butterfinger巧克力棒。
Clara looks up at the angry man. She wears bifocals and shimmery eyeshadow. She doesn't say anything. She just smiles. It's a smile so genuine that the man can't help himself. He smiles back.
问问她。她会告诉你的。你认为奥巴马会给你免费医疗吗，你认为你配吗？
Well, I don't like the Democrats in general.
克拉拉抬头看着那个愤怒的男人。她戴着双光眼镜，闪闪发光的眼影。她什么也没说。她只是笑了笑。这是一个如此真诚的微笑，以至于那个男人忍不住了。他也笑了回去。
The guy continues talking politics, but less belligerently. Clara still doesn't say a word. And by the time he collects his change, he's halfway apologizing. Clara hasn't spoken.
嗯，我总体不喜欢民主党人。
You know what? We were stuck in New York, man. Bad traffic. You have a good day. Excuse my language.
那家伙继续谈论政治，但不再那么好斗。克拉拉仍然没有说一句话。等他收好零钱时，他已经在道歉了。克拉拉还没说话。
That's an example of what we deal with, and you've got to smile.
你知道吗？我们被困在纽约了，伙计。交通太糟了。祝你有美好的一天。原谅我的语言。
That's an example of what you deal with?
这就是我们处理的例子，你必须微笑。
Yeah. Not all the time, but sometimes. They're battling the roads or this heat or traffic, especially. They're coming in fuming. They're even rough with their families. So you just say, oh, I'm sorry. I rush to get them out so that they don't have to be on you longer than possible.
这就是你处理的例子？
I only had one run-in with someone a while back who got on my goat, and I yelled back at him, which we're not supposed to do, but he just got me. I was doing a fax for a truck driver.
是的。不总是，但有时。他们正在和道路斗争，或者这热浪，或者交通，尤其是。他们进来时都在冒火。他们甚至对家人都很粗鲁。所以你只是说，噢，我很抱歉。我赶着让他们出去，这样他们就不必在你身上待得比可能的时间更久。
There's a fax machine under the cash register.
我前阵子和一个人有过一次冲突，那人惹毛了我，我对他大喊大叫，我们本不应该这样做，但他真的把我惹火了。我在为一个卡车司机发传真。
And my head is down. And all of a sudden, I hear, you're very rude. I pick my head up, and he says, you're very rude. He says, you're doing whatever you're doing down there. He says, you're not paying attention to me. I said, I'm doing a fax for someone. It's important. No, it's not, he says. I don't give a heck what you're doing down there. I'm going to report you, he says, and it's going to make my day. I couldn't take it. I said, you do that if it makes you happy.
收银机下面有一台传真机。
That's it. That's the one time she yelled at a customer.
我的头埋着。突然，我听到，你非常无礼。我抬起头，他说，你非常无礼。他说，你在下面做任何你在做的事情。他说，你没在注意我。我说，我正在为某人发传真。这很重要。不，不重要，他说。我不在乎你在下面搞什么鬼。我要举报你，他说，这会让我今天很高兴。我受不了了。我说，如果那让你高兴，你就去做吧。
You have a good night.
就是这样。那是她唯一一次对顾客大吼。
After midnight, only a few businesses are still left open in the rest stop. There's a gate blocking that room with all the New York State pamphlets, but a promotional video plays inside, in the room, behind the gate, all night long.
祝你有个美好的夜晚。
New York welcomes you to the Catskills.
午夜过后，休息站里只有几家店还开着。房间门口有一个栅栏挡住了那些纽约州的小册子，但那间房间里，在栅栏后面，整晚播放着一段宣传视频。
Two people from our team of reporters, Jay Allison and Nancy Updike, stayed up for the midnight to 8:00 AM shift. Here's Nancy first.
纽约欢迎您来到卡茨基尔。
Between midnight and 8:00 AM, the first question isn't where are you going, but why? Why are you awake at a rest stop when it's--
我们的报道团队中的两个人，杰伊·艾利森和南希·厄普代克，留下来值午夜到8点的班。这是南希先说。
2:00 AM.
在午夜到8点之间，第一个问题不是你要去哪里，而是为什么？为什么你在凌晨——
Or even--
2点。
What, 4:00 AM, I believe? Yeah, 4:00 AM in the morning, so.
甚至是——
Notice they're both laughing. It's funny, but seriously.
什么，我想是4点？是的，早上4点，所以。
Is this where you intended to be at 2:00 AM?
注意到他们都在笑。这很有趣，但说真的。
We had no idea what time we would be here, actually.
你是打算在凌晨2点出现在这里吗？
We didn't make any plans, actually.
我们其实根本不知道我们会在什么时候到这里。
We figured we would drive until we got tired and then hopefully find a place.
我们其实没有任何计划。
We'll call those people the non-planners. And then there are the planners.
我们以为我们会开到累了，然后希望找到个地方。
That's the way my son liked to drive, with no lot of traffic on the road. So that's why we're on the road this time in the morning.
我们把这些人称为无计划者。然后是有计划的人。
And then there are the people Jay's talking to, the bad planners.
那是我的儿子喜欢开车的方式，路上没那么多交通。所以这就是为什么我们在早上这个时候在路上。
Over at one of the tables, Sebastian and John are getting their last hot meal before they switch to granola. They're headed into the Adirondacks to start hiking at dawn. And they're in a good mood, laughing a lot and talking, maybe a little nervously, about bears.
然后还有杰伊在交谈的人，糟糕的计划者。
Bear bell? I'm all right.
在桌子旁，塞巴斯蒂安和约翰在换成燕麦棒之前吃他们的最后一顿热餐。他们正前往阿迪朗达克，准备在黎明时开始徒步。他们的心情很好，笑声很多，也许有点紧张地讨论着熊。
Dinner bell.
防熊铃？我没问题。
Yeah, dinner bell for them.
晚餐铃。
I'm here.
是啊，对它们来说是晚餐铃。
Yeah.
我在。
I'm here, come by.
是啊。
Are you worried about bears?
我在，过来吧。
Well, they say they're pretty active up there, so.
你担心熊吗？
You see them all over, especially when you have food around you. They come visiting, definitely.
嗯，他们说它们在那边很活跃，所以。
Yeah. You gotta watch out for that. Can't keep no food. That reminds me, I forgot the bear canister at home.
你会到处看到它们，尤其是当你周围有食物的时候。它们肯定会来拜访。
Wait, so you forgot to bring the thing that you put the food in--
是啊。你得提防那个。不能放任何食物。这让我想起来，我忘了带防熊罐头回家了。
Yeah. It's a bear canister. You put all your food in, anything with odors. You seal it up, and you stick it, like, about 100 yards from your tent.
等等，所以你忘了带那个你放食物的东西——
That's a good idea. Where is that, in your apartment?
是的。那是防熊罐。你把所有的食物放进去，任何有气味的东西。你封好它，然后你把它放在，比如，离你的帐篷大约100码的地方。
Yeah.
那是个好主意。那在哪里，在你的公寓里吗？
[LAUGHTER]
是的。
Out in the parking lot, Tony and Debbie Longo are lost, and it's Tony's fault. The thing about Tony is he's not supposed to get lost. He's a New York City homicide detective.
（笑声）
I don't know how I missed that exit. I don't know how I missed it. Big sign, Tappan Zee Bridge. There it was.
停车场外，托尼和黛比·隆戈迷路了，那是托尼的错。关于托尼的一点是，他不应该迷路。他是一个纽约市凶杀案侦探。
When you're a cop, you're not supposed to make mistakes.
我不知道我怎么错过了那个出口。我不知道我怎么错过了它。大牌子，塔潘齐大桥。它就在那儿。
Yeah, not the direction. The direction thing has to be down pat. I lost control.
当你是个警察时，你不应该犯错。
I really hate my whole family right now. They didn't want to leave in the morning. God forbid we leave in the morning.
是的，不是方向。方向问题必须非常熟练。我失去了控制。
Next time you'll leave in the morning.
我现在真的非常讨厌我的全家。他们不想在早上出发。上帝保佑我们早上出发。
Oh, we'll leave in the morning next time.
下次你会早上出发的。
Next time, I'm not coming.
噢，下次我们会早上出发。
It's after 3:00 in the morning, and they've been lost for hours. And Debbie Longo says she's not a happy camper. But you can tell she is.
下次，我不来了。
There's no soft serve, and it's not taking my money. I don't care anymore. I don't care. I'm going to get fat, and I don't care. I'm going to blow up like a balloon. And you're going to have a big fat wife.
现在是凌晨3点过后，他们已经迷路好几个小时了。黛比·隆戈说她不是一个快乐的露营者。但你可以看出她是。
That's OK.
没有软冰淇淋，而且它不收我的钱。我不在乎了。我不在乎。我要变胖，我不在乎。我要像个气球一样炸开。然后你会有个又大又胖的老婆。
OK.
没关系。
But we stay happy.
好的。
Isn't there some truism about if you want to test your relationship, go on a long drive together? What I'm saying is, I'm expecting a lot of grouchiness here at the rest stop during the graveyard shift-- scowls, sniping, mutual recrimination.
但我们依然快乐。
Instead, I keep seeing couple after couple walk up to the glass doors of the rest stop and reach for each other's hands right before they walk through. Instinctively, like, here we go, you and me. Couples of every age-- 20s, 40s, 60s.
关于如果你想测试你们的关系，一起长途驾驶，是不是有什么真理？我想说的是，我在期待休息站在午夜值班期间有很多暴躁——冷嘲热讽、互相指责。
What are your names?
相反，我一直看到一对又一对的情侣走到休息站的玻璃门前，在走进去之前伸手去牵对方。本能地，就像，我们走吧，你和我。各个年龄段的情侣——20多岁，40多岁，60多岁。
Edetta.
你们叫什么名字？
And I'm Peter.
埃黛塔。
Edetta and Peter are on a five-hour drive to pick up their kids from summer camp, their first time at camp. In other words, a Parenting 101 trip-- unexciting, long, and happening at an inconvenient time. But listen to them laughing.
我是彼得。
Did the kids want to go, or did you say, "You're going?"
埃黛塔和彼得正开车五个小时去接他们参加夏令营的孩子，这是他们第一次参加夏令营。换句话说，一次育儿101旅行——不刺激、漫长，而且发生在不方便的时间。但听听他们的笑声。
We kind of made them go.
孩子们想去，还是你说，“你去”？
[LAUGHTER]
我们算是逼他们去的。
And our oldest left for college exactly for the same time, so it works well.
（笑声）
Free time for ourselves, and they have free time for themselves.
而且我们的老大正好在同一时间去上大学，所以这很合适。
[LAUGHTER]
我们有自己的空闲时间，他们有自己的空闲时间。
It's at this point that I blurt out the most obvious and inappropriate question.
（笑声）
What did you do with your free time?
就在这时，我不假思索地脱口而出最明显且不恰当的问题。
Which they handle admirably.
你们用空闲时间做了什么？
We really had time to connect.
他们处理得非常令人钦佩。
Had some romantic dinners and spend time together.
我们确实有时间建立联系。
When was the last time you had time to do that before this?
吃了一些浪漫的晚餐并共度时光。
Oh, 20 years ago.
在这之前你上一次有时间做那个是什么时候？
[LAUGHTER]
噢，20年前。
Oh, I remember back then.
（笑声）
And there's more giddiness inside the rest stop. Another couple, Lisa and Marcus.
噢，我记得那时候。
Did you see me giving him little kisses and telling him how cute he was when he walked in?
休息站里还有更多的眩晕感。另一对情侣，丽莎和马库斯。
Lisa and Marcus, as you can tell, are in deep. They're looking at a map on the wall of this half-closed rest stop on their way up to Lake Champlain to go camping. It's the middle of the night. They've gotten lost already, not sure where they're going to sleep. But the two of them cannot stop smiling. I can feel endorphins radiating from them in waves. They met salsa dancing less than a year ago, and love is making them ambitious.
你看到我给他小吻并告诉他他进来时有多可爱了吗？
We're planning on maybe moving to Argentina.
丽莎和马库斯，如你所见，爱得很深。他们正在看这个半关门的休息站墙上的地图，正在去尚普兰湖露营的路上。现在是午夜。他们已经迷路了，不确定要在哪里睡觉。但他们俩笑个不停。我能感觉到内啡肽从他们身上一波接一波地辐射出来。他们不到一年前通过萨尔萨舞认识，爱使他们变得雄心勃勃。
And we started already dancing tango here in Philadelphia. So we want to become professional tango dancers. No, that's a joke.
我们计划也许搬到阿根廷。
No, it's not.
而且我们已经在费城开始跳探戈了。所以我们想成为职业探戈舞者。不，那是开玩笑。
Outside the rest stop, Katarina and Johnny are sitting next to each other on a bench. Not a bench in a beautiful park, a bench looking out on a highway and a parking lot. Of course they don't care. In fact, they seem not to have noticed at all.
不，那不是。
We're going to Montreal, Canada.
休息站外，卡塔琳娜和约翰尼坐在一起。不是在美丽的公园长凳上，而是一个面对高速公路和停车场的长凳上。当然他们不在乎。事实上，他们似乎根本没注意到。
You're going to Montreal?
我们要去加拿大蒙特利尔。
Mm-hmm.
你们要去蒙特利尔？
Yeah, we're coming from New York, and we're going to Montreal.
嗯。
Right, yeah.
是的，我们从纽约来，我们要去蒙特利尔。
Johnny is finishing up his residency, but he's not sure he even wants to be a doctor. 35 years old with more than $200,000 in school debt. But he doesn't want to talk about that. He's on a road trip with his girl. He brushes off my questions, leans into the microphone, and steers us back to what we should be talking about.
对，是啊。
(SINGING) Love me tender, love me true, never let me go. Oh my god.
约翰尼即将完成他的住院实习，但他甚至不确定他是否想成为一名医生。35岁，背负着超过20万美元的学费债务。但他不想谈论那个。他和他的女孩正在公路旅行。他摆脱了我的问题，靠向话筒，把我们带回我们应该讨论的事情上。
But even at a rest stop that's fizzy with love, there is heartache. As I'm standing outside, a man asks what I'm doing. So I ask what he's doing. We end up talking for a while. His name is Dan. He's driving back to upstate New York after a day in New York City.
（唱歌）爱我温柔，爱我真实，永远别让我走。噢天哪。
Spent some time with my boys.
但即使在一个充满爱情的休息站，也有心碎。当我站在外面时，一个人问我在做什么。所以我问他在做什么。我们最后聊了一会儿。他叫丹。他在纽约市度过一天后开车回纽约州北部。
How old are they?
和我的孩子们待了一会儿。
19 and 20-- oh my god-- 23.
他们多大了？
How often do you see them?
19和20——噢天哪——23。
Not often enough. I'm trying to make it more regular 'cause I just got divorced, like, a year or so ago, and so. They're staying with their mom, so I'm seeing less of them. Try to get to see them, like, once a month.
你多久见到他们一次？
How is the divorce for them?
不够频繁。我正试着让它更规律，因为我刚离婚，大概一年多前，所以。他们和妈妈待在一起，所以我见他们的次数变少了。试着去见他们，大概一个月一次。
I don't really know. It seems to be OK for them, you know? It's a little weird still, but we still try to do things together and--
离婚对他们来说怎么样？
You and your ex-wife and the kids?
我不知道。对他们来说似乎还可以，你知道吗？还有点怪，但我们仍然试着一起做事情和——
No, I don't do things with her anymore. Last year, my son's 18th birthday, we went skydiving together.
你和你前妻以及孩子们？
All four of you.
不，我不再和她一起做事了。去年，我儿子的18岁生日，我们一起跳伞。
Yeah, all four of us. Like, she wanted her boyfriend to come. And I was like-- I actually called him and said, don't come.
你们四个人。
You called him?
是的，我们四个人。就像，她想让她男朋友来。而且我当时——我实际上给他打了电话说，别来。
Yeah. I called him, left him a message. It was a very polite message. And I was like, Michael, please don't come.
你认识他。你有他的号码。
You know him. You have his number.
是的。我认识他，是的。所以。那是一件艰难的事。她想让他来，就像，参加我儿子的18岁生日。而那就像，真的，那太怪了。尝试和你的前任做朋友是一件非常奇怪的事，然后你真的不能成为朋友。然后你有了这个新的女朋友，然后这就像，这真是一件如此困难的事。
Yeah. I knew him, yeah. So. It was a tough thing. She wanted him to come and, like, go on my son's 18th birthday. And it was like, really, it was just too weird. It's a very weird thing, trying to be friends with your ex, and then you can't really be friends. And then you have this other girlfriend, and then it's just like it's such a difficult thing.
她不想让我去房子接男孩们。然后有一周，我们在进行愉快的对话，下周，那样的事情就出现了。你会觉得——你有那个东西。你想给那个人打电话，对他大吼大叫，和他谈论它。但你没有那种关系了。
She didn't want me to go to the house to pick the boys up. And then one week, we're having a good conversation, and next week, something like that comes up. And you're like-- you have the thing. You want to call that person, and yell at them, and talk to them about it. But you don't have that relationship anymore.
当你意识到，对，我们没有那种关系了，那是艰难的时刻。
That's a hard moment, when you realize, right, we don't have that relationship anymore.
试着去心理咨询什么的，试着让她回来。
Try to go to counseling and stuff and try to get her to come back.
她不想去心理咨询？
She didn't want to go to counseling?
她和我去了一次，但后来她还是不停地见那个家伙，那个她正在见的别的家伙。所以我的意思是，那样子——我让她付了自付额，然后我们就离开了。
She went with me one time, but then she wouldn't stop seeing this guy, this other guy she was seeing. So I mean, that kind of-- I made her pay the copay and we left.
别的那个家伙，迈克尔。
This other guy, Michael.
是的。我实际上见过他。我在一个聚会上见过他，她和他成为了朋友。他们变得越来越亲密。而不是试着和我解决问题，她正试着和他解决问题，所以——我经常想到这个。我责怪自己作为父亲、作为丈夫或者其他什么地方做错了。我基本上45岁了，我想我生命的一半已经结束了。我真的在试着弄清楚下半年该做什么。
Yeah. I had actually met him. I had met him at a party and her and him had become friends. And they just became more and more intimate. And instead of trying to work stuff out with me, she was trying to work stuff out with him, so-- I just think about it a lot. I beat myself up for where did I go wrong as a father, as a husband or whatever. And I'm basically 45 years old, and I figure half my life is over. And I'm really trying to figure out what to do with the next half.
我知道这只是一个休息站，但真的，某种爱的力场今晚在这里生效了。因为猜怎么着？丹有了个新女朋友。她正和他一起在休息站，只是不想对着话筒说话。他们通过一个单身团体认识，他们在一起的时间足够长，以至于开始见对方的孩子了。这仍然很复杂，但哇，感觉太棒了。
I know this is just a rest stop, but really, some kind of love force field is in effect here tonight. Because guess what? Dan has a new girlfriend. She's at the rest stop with him, just doesn't want to talk into a microphone. They met through a singles group, and they've been together long enough that they've started meeting each other's kids. It's still complicated, but wow, it feels great.
我今晚刚告诉她。我说我不知道如果生命中没有她我会做什么。我的意思是，这是——我找到了一个真正爱我的女人。而且我，就像，被那个彻底打倒了，你知道吗？这只是，它是——
I just told her tonight. I said I don't know what I would do with somebody else in my life. I mean, this is-- I found a woman that really loves me. And I'm, like, so over bowled by that, you know? It's just, it's--
这就像个奇迹。
It's like a miracle.
是的，是啊。我对未来很乐观。非常乐观。
Yeah, it is. I'm optimistic about the future. Very optimistic.
在停车场，当我第一次从远处看到史蒂夫G时，我以为他是裸体的。
In the parking lot, when I first saw Stevie G from a distance, I thought he was naked.
现在，我正在放松臀部的肌肉。
And right now, I'm de-kinking the muscles in my buttock.
然后他把一条腿踢到头顶上方，我看到他穿着小白健身鞋。
Then he kicked one leg in the air above his head, and I saw he was wearing little white gym shoes.
噢，它打开了髋关节前部的青春之泉。
Oh, it opens up the Fountain of Youth in the front of the hip joint.
然后他跳进一束光里，我看到他实际上穿着细小的黑色尼龙短裤。史蒂夫G教身体锻炼、普拉提、瑜伽、按摩之类的。他在这个休息站停留是为了拉伸和活动。不过很难不注意到，虽然史蒂夫在停车场锻炼，但他同时在抽一支手卷烟。
And then he jumped into a pool of light, and I saw he actually had on some tiny black nylon shorts. Stevie G teaches bodywork, pilates, yoga, massage, and such. And he stopped at this rest stop to stretch and move. It's hard not to notice, though, that while Stevie is working out in the parking lot, he's simultaneously smoking a hand-rolled cigarette.
这就是我，你知道吗？不幸的是，我在污染我的肺，但它们运转良好。我每天清理它们。
That's what I am, you know? Unfortunately, I'm polluting my lungs, but they're doing well. I clean them out on a daily basis.
你如何清理它们？
How do you clean them out?
通常是跑步、蒸气、冥想呼吸的混合，而不是吞下我咳出的东西。我总是把它吐出来。就像，我有一个小杯子。我可以吐出所有——我从来不吞下它。
Usually a mixture of running, and steaming, and meditational breathing, and not swallowing what I cough up. I always spit it out. Like, I have a little cup. I can spit out all-- I don't never swallow it.
顺便说一句，我们的谈话发生在史蒂夫的车辆旁边，这在他生活中占有很大比重。那是一辆他在伍德斯托克弄到的老黄色校车，用来开始一个志愿者服务项目。
Our conversation, by the way, is happening next to Stevie's vehicle, which figures largely in his life. It's an old yellow school bus he got up in Woodstock to start a volunteer service program.
接送喝醉的人，比如，走进酒吧找那些，说，好吧，谁看起来真的喝大了？提供他们免费回家。
Picking up the drunk people, like, going into the bars and finding the ones and say, all right, who looks really bombed? Offer them a free ride home.
但现在史蒂夫G对巴士有了更大的愿景。他想建造一个由校车组成的健康中心。在他离开休息站之前，史蒂夫G拿出一个大泡沫滚筒，带它去他最喜欢的地方进行最后的拉伸。
But now Stevie G has a larger vision for the bus. He wants to build a health center made of school buses. Before he leaves the rest stop, Stevie G gets out a big foam roller and takes it to his favorite spot for a final stretch.
好了，我们一侧有所有的大18轮卡车。我们在另一边有所有的小车。我们在87号公路上。这是我觉得最干净的地方。你只需要小心看狗是否来过。
All right, we got all the big 18 wheeler trucks on one side. We've got all the smaller cars over here on the other. We are on 87 highway. This is where I think it's the cleanest. You just got to watch out to see if the dogs have been here.
芝麻开门，收紧肚子，燃烧脂肪，美国。你得从你那肥屁股上起来做点什么好的，就像固体橡木一样好的东西。走出去帮助别人。尤其是帮助你自己成为最好的自己，这样你就不会成为一个暴躁的老傻瓜。现在我们都得爬上山。
Abracadabra, scoop that belly, burn the jelly, America. You gotta get off your fat one and do something good, something good like the solid oak wood. Get out there and help others. And especially help yourself to be your best, so that you are not a cranky old fool. Now we all got to pull up the hill.
史蒂夫在人行道上滚动，卡车司机从驾驶室里向下看着他。他没注意到。当他彻底放松时，他拿起滚筒回到他的车上。
Stevie rolls all around the sidewalk, with truckers looking down at him from their cabs. He doesn't notice. When he's all loosened up, he picks up his roller and heads back to his vehicle.
（发动机启动）
[ENGINE STARTING]
噢，听起来不错。那是我的宝贝。保重。放轻松。
Oh, it sounds good. That's my baby. Take care. Take it easy.
史蒂夫G咳出一些痰，吐掉，然后前往伍德斯托克。
Stevie G coughs up some phlegm, spits it out, and heads off for Woodstock.
是早晨了。家麻雀在休息站门外的树里疯狂地聚集。站在停车场里，九岁的布莱恩·贝尔科看起来其实有点像只鸟。他的眼睛很亮。他的手臂在身体两侧僵硬地稍微张开像翅膀。当他对着话筒说话时，他把头向前点，就像他在啄它。
It's morning. English sparrows are congregating like crazy in the trees just outside the rest stop doors. Standing out in the parking lot, nine-year-old Brian Belco looks kind of like a bird, actually. His eyes are bright. His arms are stiff at his sides and held out a bit like wings. And when he speaks into the microphone, he bobs his head forward, like he's pecking at it.
我们要去斯旺顿矿钓鱼。
We're going fishing up in Swanton's Mine.
是啊，你要捕什么？
Yeah, what are you going to catch?
鲈鱼、狗鱼、梭鱼、河鲈。
Bass, pike, pickerel, perch.
哇，听起来你以前做过。
Wow, it sounds like you've done this before.
是的。但传统是从我的家人开始的。是从我的曾祖父开始的。
Yep. But the tradition started with my family. It started with my great grandfather.
是这样吗？
Is that right?
我的曾祖父是个伟大的渔夫。他真的喜欢钓鱼，所以他去了尚普兰湖。有些小屋就是建在1842年战争的历史战场上，尚普兰湖战役。
My great grandfather was a great fisherman. He really liked fishing, so he went up to Lake Champlain. And some of the cabins were built right over the historic battlefield of the war in 1842, the Battle of Lake Champlain.
你是个学生。
You're a student.
这是我第一次电台采访。
This is my first radio interview ever.
真的吗？
Really?
是的。
Yep.
你做得很好。
You did great.
我知道。我真的、真的非常兴奋。
I know. I'm really, really excited.
说再见。
Say goodbye.
再见。
Bye.
再见。祝你有美好的假期。
Bye. Have a great vacation.
谢谢。
Thanks.
随着新的一天的到来，在我们走之前我们只有时间写最后一个备注。来自普拉特基尔和缅因州休息站之间战斗的最终统计。在下午结束时，在我们普拉特基尔的两天之后，我可以告诉你，两个休息站的生意都没真正好转。在周六下午两天之后，罗伯特告诉我他周末只有一个安慰——他打败了安迪。
And with the new day here, we have just the time for one final note before we go. Final tallies from the battle between the rest stops in Plattekill and Maine. At the end of the afternoon, after our two days in Plattekill, I can report to you that business never really picked up for either rest stop. And after two days on Saturday afternoon, Robert told me he only had one consolation for the weekend-- he beat Andy.
我是那一天的王。我打败了安迪，红袜队被洋基队痛打和屠杀了。不幸的是，当你的销售额少了七千块钱时，成为一天的王并没有那么好。每个人都情绪低落。所以这对每个人来说都是糟糕的一天。缅因州——安迪发了一个简短的便条，根本没达到他的数字。
I'm the king for the day. I beat Andy, and the Red Sox got smacked around and massacred by the Yankees. The unfortunate thing is being king for the day when you miss your sales by seven grand isn't so good. And everybody was down. So it was a bad day for everybody. Maine-- Andy sent out a quick note, not hitting his numbers at all.
但你知道，我们为下一个周末做好了准备。我们还有两个周末要过。我仍然认为他们会来。我的意思是，是的，在这个行业，你必须保持积极。
But you know, we're ready for next weekend. We still got two more weekends to go. I still think they're coming. I mean, yeah, in this business, you've got to be positive.
当我离开时，他两天落后了约12,000美元，比他需要的低了7%或8%。但他所说的所有这些雨可能会让秋天北部的叶子变得非常美丽。很多人可能会为了看那些叶子而上路。他仍然可以扭转这个局面。
When I left, he was around $12,000 down for two days, 7% or 8% lower than where he needed to be. But all this rain, he said, could make for really beautiful leaves upstate come the fall. A lot of people could get on the roads for that to look at those leaves. He could still turn this around.
今天的节目是在2009年报道的。在此后的几年里，总经理罗伯特被多次提拔。他现在是Motorways的高级总监，监督纽约州高速公路、缅因州收费公路的旅行广场，以及马萨诸塞州的一些星巴克——这意味着，当然，普拉特基尔和肯纳邦克波特的安迪之间的竞争结束了。虽然，罗伯特说，他们确实还在争论棒球。
Today's show was reported in 2009. In the years since, Robert, the general manager, has been promoted several times. He's now a senior director of Motorways, overseeing travel plazas in the New York Thruway, the main turnpike, and a few Starbucks in Massachusetts-- which means, of course, that the competition between Plattekill and Andy in Kennebunkport came to an end. Though, Robert says, they do still argue about baseball.
你仍然可以在普拉特基尔找到伦尼·惠特提供旅游建议，克拉拉·德拉贡在收银台后面，尽管他们已经停止使用J-1签证引进外国学生。
You can still find Lenny Wheat dispensing travel advice and Clara Dragon behind the register at Plattekill, though they've stopped using J-1 visas to bring in foreign students.
嗯，我们的节目今天是由肖恩·科尔和我自己制作的，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·玛丽、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。今天节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。今天重播的额外制作来自杰西卡·卢森霍普、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼。
Well, our program was produced today by Sean Cole and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Marie, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alyssa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Additional production on today's rerun from Jessica Lussenhop, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney.
今天特别感谢前纽约州州长戴维·帕特森办公室的摩根·胡克，纽约州高速公路管理局，以及HMS Host的希利亚·麦基。我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换机构PRX提供给公共广播电台。
Special thanks today to Morgan Hook, from former New York Governor David Patterson's office, to the New York State Thruway Authority, and to Shelia McGee at HMS Host. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他说不要相信他的名声。不要相信人们关于他的言论。那不是真的。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who says do not believe his reputation. Do not believe what people say about him. It's not true.
我不觉得我是一个大疯墨西哥人。我真的只是一个温柔的巨人。
I don't think I'm a big crazy Mexican at all. I'm a gentle giant, really.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
（音乐 - SILVEROOT，“休息站”）
[MUSIC - SILVEROOT, "REST STOP"]
[音乐 - SILVEROOT, "REST STOP"]